next with tin and lead solder they fuse  a threaded neck ring to the bottom Edge  this ring attaches the Bonnet to the  helmet's breastplate which bolts to the  collar of the diver's dry suit then they  solder a base to the face plate opening  like all the helmet's components it's  made of red brass which is more durable  than standard brass due to its higher  copper content  through a template they drill holes into  a banana shaped brass exhaust tube it  enables the diver's exhaled air to exit  the helmet they solder the exhaust to  the Bonnet positioning the non  perforated end over a hole near the  diver's mouth and the perforated end at  the rear this directs air bubbles behind  the diver so as not to obstruct The View  then they solder on the remaining  components including three window bases